今天的题目是歌词灵感与故事来源之截取
在这个流行音乐圈里面有几种合作状况
第一个就是说发稿的
发稿的歌词通常你不太能去呃
决定它的主题
因为他只要是发稿
只要有竞争
他一定会先给一个议题
一个他们想要的slogan
那有时候新人去竞争比稿很辛苦
之前的课堂上有讲过
那你怎么去克服呢
就是说有时候我都还会写两份
就是新人的阶段
就是他一个melody旋律比稿
可能三个作词者底稿
那别人都只交一份
我交两份几率大一点
歌词灵感
有时候从日常生活中可以得到某一部分的线索
或者是资料
举例来讲
你可能看了一场电影
你可能看了一本小说或者是一趟的旅游
记得养成习惯
准备一个小册子
不要太大
随身携带
因为有时候放在包包
哪一天你那个包包没有带
或是这一趟的出门不太适合带包包
你有时候就忘记了手写
有手写的触感
当然手机是可以记录一些事情
但是我习惯用手写
因为手写的当下等于你又复习了一遍
那手机记事情当然是很快按按按按按
然后又处理别的事情
有时候你就忽略它了
但是因为你集中在本子上
那本子你可以拿来看诶
哪一天有个很特别的句子
哪一天有个很很就是很惊喜的一个想法
就把它记在本子上
写在纸本上
而不要用手机去记载
因为手机的功能太多了
你会分心
但是把所有的想法
所有看得到的灵感
一些线索资料集中在一个手写的小册子里面
这等于也是一种仪式感
寄东西的仪式感
这个东西也变成你自己的收藏
改天你真的已经进入这个圈子了
你会回想就拿手写的笔记本来看哇
3年前写下这个句子
话有用的哇
半年前写下了这一行格子诶
后来给谁发表了
这不是很好吗
但是你记在手机里面才冷冰冰的
手机里面的资料只能当一种储存
它是没有表情的
它也没有温度
手写的东西才有温度
养成这个仪式感的习
习惯
接下来我先用一首歌
来当做今天这个议题的范例
那就是青花瓷
青花瓷这首歌是先有曲再有词
我通常跟作曲者合作的一个比例八比一
什么是八比一
就是八首歌里面有七首是先有曲再有词
只有一首
先有词再有曲
因为我的歌词a one a two b one b two很清楚
字句长短很适合八小节
所以基本上有时候是这样是可行的
但是多数的状态下
人家会希望先决定旋律
因为歌词可以修改
歌词很好修改旋律
你一动的话
搞不好这个和弦不对了
你就麻烦了
而且旋律可以跟动的音超过太多小节的话
基本上你要重写了
你可以换词吗
心碎换悲伤
然后落泪换憔悴
连韵脚都没换
接下来就是分享青花瓷这首歌
当初的创作的过程
一开始先拿到周同学的曲
那时候我刚好对古文物很有兴趣
一直到现在都还是了
然后就看了很多青铜器的东西
我想说青铜器这么刚强的一个一个器皿
那如果用很柔性的语处来写
应该很特别
我一开始这首歌叫青铜器
但是后来自己又觉得好像不对
因为青铜器在春秋战国时期
也被同时浇灌成兵器厮杀砍伐的那种兵器
觉得暴戾之气太重
而且如果周同学今天在演唱会的场合
所以接下来为各位带这首青铜器
就很奇怪了
人家以为要哼哼哈嘿的
就觉得好dancer要出来了
没有没有
这是情歌
不能这样子
青铜器取消
第二个选择是汝窑
我觉得汝窑的颜色很美
就是天青色
其实天青色是汝窑的颜色
而不是青花瓷的颜色
之所以为什么
等一下再来解释
传世的汝窑很少
什么叫传世
它不是出土瓷器
不容易出土
又完整
出土完整的通通常都是青铜器
或是一些漆器石碑
因为它的材质的关系
它不容易破损
那瓷器的东西有时候出土之后还要修补
因为汝窑传世的剑术非常的少
全世界范围也就60几间而已
你想想看哦
以前在烧窑的时候
一个窑洞通常他们都是推四五十件进去
看窑的大小
二三十件甚至上百件
一起烧
这么多年来已经烧了成千上万件
然后历史绝大多数灰飞在历史的尘埃中
居然只有60几件
而且绝大多数在国家等级的博物馆里
汝窑的拍卖价非常非常的高
因为它很罕见
很珍贵
所以当初第二个选项用汝窑的意思
就是说他很很稀罕
很珍贵
青铜器上面有个铭文
就殷商时期的经文
殷商起的经文
我们现在很看不懂你了不起
看得懂篆刻的篆书
篆是秦代的文字
秦篆
那经文就更古老
经文是介于甲骨文跟篆刻的中间
那我想说用这个罕见的文字来象征爱情的神秘
那最后放弃了嘛
因为青铜纪这个实在太阳刚了
不太像爱情
你只是抒情歌
第二个选项是汝窑
因为汝窑的珍贵性
可以象征爱情的誓言
所以我第二个选项用汝窑三点水
一个女开始写了
我就写天津色等烟雨
而我在等你
他也是对账诶自己很满意
觉得诶很特别
而且天津社这个典故是因为我看了一个传说
就是汝窑
当初汝窑烧制成功的时候
然后有两种版本
一个是五代的世宗柴荣
他说雨过天青云破处这般颜色作将来
那有一说是这句话是宋徽宗说的
他的意思是说
下过雨之后
云跟云中间的破开处有个天空
那个天空的那个青色非常的美
因为一阵大雨把空气中的尘埃洗涤得很干净
之后
它会破开一个天空色
那这个天空色就是所谓的天青色
天青色是汝窑的颜色
我觉得这个形容很美
雨过天青云破处
这个天青就是天晴的意思
这般颜色做将来就这种颜色就是我追求的
在将来希望由黑暗变光明诶
觉得这个寓意很好哦
就开始写
后来还是放弃了
因为呢汝窑很罕见
流行音乐毕竟是通俗文化
最好是能望文生义哦
一听就觉得这是情歌
那一首歌叫汝窑
你怎么想象这到底是是讲乡愁吗
还是讲悲伤
你不知道
后来就放弃了
但是我副歌的第一行舍不得放弃
我就没有换
慢慢慢慢找诶
找到了青花瓷
青花瓷的能见度很高
而且大家一听到青花瓷
脑海中就有青花瓷那个线条
那个颜色
青花布局在瓷器上的颜色
而且还有个花字
哎我觉得这个蛮好的
可是我副歌我不想换呐
我不想改
后来呢我就照用
重点是我没有讲
人家不晓得不晓得说天青色是汝窑的颜色
天青色是不是青花瓷的颜色
所以呢这个是创作的过程中去搜集资料
因为呢你有些灵感是生活周遭给你的刺激
可能看到一个朋友的故事
他跟你哭诉
男朋友走掉啦
劈腿啊什么的
有些是自己的生活的一种经历
所有的经历是可能看了一个电影
看了一个展览
然后去触发了你的想象
记得这个想象
哪怕是一行字
一个片语都可以养成习惯
有个小本子专门收集你灵光乍现
天外飞来一笔的灵感
接下来就分享另外一首歌词
那就是大吼带蔡同学
蔡依林的倒带
之前网友就是算是八卦吧
绝对是周同学写给他的
NO不是是我写给我前女友的
今天在这里哦
周
要澄清这两个人
我前女友就是要分手了
那他那个感触太深了啦
因为情感的东西占了流行音乐的主流
那因为情感最容易疗愈人心嘛
所以那时候我就啊就是很伤感
然后有些段落还边写边哭
哈哈这个例子很罕见的
这个同学也不太需要学好
OK看一下这首歌的一个结构
这首歌押的是爱韵爱韵
你看哈
他的副歌终于看开
爱回不来
而你总是太晚明白
最后才把话说开
哭着求我留下来
那哭的人是我啦
然后整首歌这个韵脚是流畅的
是协调的
你就一韵到底没有关系
这整首歌的韵脚是同一个他的副歌的基点
其实是终于看开爱回不来
然后又重复唱
终于看开爱回不来
但是呢我却没有用
终于看开
当歌迷终于看开
太白话了
你知道吗
都说点歌诶
你干嘛呢
K去K房点歌
我要点首
终于终于看开
你是看开什么东西
后来我想说
不要爱回不来
好像也很口语
记得歌名的原创性
最好是人家没有用过的
像我之前写东风破
这个是自创的词汇
因为东风破那个破字是仿宋代词排名的一个曲
破音乐到最高点等于是就是炸开来那种感觉
所以东风波是仿词牌名写的
基本上这个三个字都是原创
就是词牌名也没有这三个字
那是原创性很高的歌名
歌迷要有原创性
那最简单的方法是因为像网络很发达
像我很久以前写一首威廉古堡
其实一开始还叫吸血鬼
我就上网去查嗯
吸血鬼有人用了
好吧算了
我就开始找关键字诶
我发现威廉古堡的意境跟画面感
可能比吸血鬼还好
后来左思右想
找了老半天哦
找到关键字倒带
像歌词上有写到从我脸上的苍白
看到记忆慢下来过去
甜蜜在倒带
只是感觉已经不在
甜蜜在倒带咯
你在回想咯
你在回忆咯
有画面感咯
而且倒带很少拿来当歌的名字
就是以前有卡带的那个年代倒带很好
他他比终于看开跟爱回不来好太多了
那这个是生活上的一个遭遇了
就说让作词人通常不会是很多都是自身的故事
这个例子很罕见
那我只是强调
就是说我们的灵感来源有很多类别
有时候是朋友的故事
有时候是自己的遭遇
有时候是看了一部电影
一本小说
一场戏剧
看的时候觉得哎呀这个感觉好奇怪哦
说不上来你就不管他
说不上来就写什么字
你说不上来那种感觉
就把它记录下来
哪一天卡巴就用在哪一首歌的副歌
所以呢各位同学
这堂课有很多创作上的武林秘籍
第一个是韵脚表
第二个是灵感
不记得哦
灵感的小册子
灵感部
这是很重要的
要养成习惯
歌词本身像故事一样
所以你前后句一定要相互的呼应
我记得一定要对仗
但是意思要连贯
我再举个例
应该开心的地带
你给的全是空白
为什么空白哦
下一行的解释
一个人假日发呆
找不到人陪我看海
因为他一天到晚忙工作啊
没办法陪这个女生
那个她那就是我了
我在幸福的门外却一直都进不来
你累积给的伤害
我是真的很难释怀
他就觉得你你道歉也没有用
因为累积的嘛
他觉得他青春陪你这么长
我再举一段副歌
终于看开爱回不来
而你总是太晚明白
最后才把话说开
哭着求我留下来
跟你总是太晚
明白是呼应的哦
然后再来
因为副歌第一行是重复
只是记忆点
这是比较主流的写法
但我建议初学者就照这个主流去去写
就是副歌的第一行
音乐基点最强的地方的那那行中文字
或所谓的歌词
就让它重复
你看第二段的歌词也是重复哦
终于看开
爱回不来
这个是重复的
然后下面才换
我们面前太多阻碍你的手却放不开
宁愿没出息
求我别离开
创作歌词有很多种形式跟方法
去从生活中找画面感
找灵感
像我很久以前看的一本书叫洛阳全然记
很特别
北魏时期的一本著作
一个叫杨炫之写的
他就是1500年前经过了洛阳哇
洛阳很兴盛
那时候佛教很发达
我看了很多佛寺都大概的很辉煌
哎
过个几年后
因为战争的关系哇
佛寺请他了
毁坏了
他觉得很感伤
他是个心思细腻的人
为什么讲心思细腻
他把一些佛寺的尺寸丈量或是否是亲他的原因
历史上的变故都把它记载下来
绝本洛阳全然记
全然是音译
就是佛寺的意思
那我觉得哇好特别好像那个时期的文字纪录片
我看了就觉得好特别
我就虚拟的一个历史故事
写下烟花易冷
烟花易冷
人事易分
这也是对仗的
就说我是描述哇有个地方很繁荣
后来毁坏了
然后这个人在经历的时候
女主角已经不在了
去佛寺出家剃度了
将军回来的时候才发现
他魂影梦系的那个女子已经削发为尼了
就是很感伤
那我就是把看到的书的故事的内容
消化成文字作品
生活中有太多的养分
这里的养分不是只有书籍而已哦
它可能是一个秀
一场演唱会
一个表演
甚至一趟旅游
我很鼓励大家是多方面的涉猎
像我因为对当代艺术也蛮有兴趣的
我会去看展
看了展之后
你会发现说天哪
这世界好多人的想法都跟我们不一样
重点这个不一样才丰富了我们的生活
如果每个人想法都一样
每个人专注对领域都一样
那世界就很无聊了嘛
当代艺术里面有一个很特别的画
孟克挪威的画家
他画了一个呐喊
你知道吗
大概在十几年前
他的拍卖价得标价落锤价7亿人民币
7亿人民币可以盖一个美术馆呢
他就是一幅画
然后我给大家看一下
这幅画应该是除了蒙娜丽莎之外
在西洋美术史里面占有非常重要的地位
你就觉得这个你也会啊
有没有这种抽象的画风线条
然后大概颜色也很省
大概只有三种颜色
然后画来画一张
这个是粉蜡笔
不是水彩笔
粉蜡笔可能更便宜吧
就这样子奇异
不要开玩笑了吧
欣赏艺术的时候呢
记得很多点要去顾及他什么时候画的
1895年
1895年什么概念
李鸿章老先生跟伊藤博文签下了马关条约
李鸿章诶感觉他是古代的人呢
跟他同个年代
你可以想象吗
李鸿章那个年代
中国的文人画家还在画工笔画
还在泼墨山水
人家已经有表现主义抽象的语法在描述心情了
这个差距有多大
你知道吗
有些画风的价值在于时间轴的跨度
然后在艺术史里面的位置
就是说那时候工业革命结束没多久
他是代表说进入工业革命之后
很多的人力都仰赖机机械社会变得很沉重
变得比较没有那么的人文
他某种程度在控诉工业革命带来的压力
精神压力
在那个时间轴
100多年前有这样子的线条
这样子的画风
那是一个多特别的观察
就说你这个画家有能力观察到现象
然后把它用绘画的方式画下来
它的价值在懂得人的心里面
那有些绘画的价值在于历史上的位置
他在这个时间点做这个事情
就没有人能超越他了
有时候我们看到当代艺术的画作
你看久了好像觉得诶这个线条好像在运动啊
这个线条让我心里很平静
这可是你不能很浮躁的用价值去定位它
就说但可能每个领域你不是很懂
那不是很懂
才是生命的乐趣
你全部都懂了
你干嘛
你是哪里也不用去啦
就天才就一个天才住在家里面啊
然后什么事也不用干了
因为你什么领域你都懂
那就无聊了嘛
就看不懂才好玩
因为他有一个创作的原因跟心理因素
跟创作的历程跟价值
像草间弥生
他那个圆点的话
南瓜有没有
那凭什么他受到这么大的欢迎
请记得时间轴
草间弥生90几岁了
人家在50年前就做这个事情了
再举几个例子
像安藤忠雄
他不是建筑有清水膜吗
你要想想看哦
当大家都开始粉刷墙壁
贴瓷砖的时候
它还原墙壁原来的颜色
素颜清水膜的意思是水泥的颜色
我干嘛需要别的东西呢
树树人不是很好看吗
墙壁的素人
墙壁的素颜就是他的清水膜
他持之以恒在做这个领域的创作
三宅一生
他衣服是皱褶
他就觉得说衣服为什么要烫平
大家都烫平的时候
我就不烫平
我就觉得衣服应该有自己的表情
他的衣服的设计的特色就是很多皱褶
然后蔡国强火药爆破哎
火药爆破我也会啊
你给我鞭炮我也会啊
问题是他火药爆破之后变成一幅画
变成一个装置艺术
他先做到这个的
有时候比的不是谁先想到
而是谁先做到很多艺术的领域
我们去看就会有乐趣
那我刚刚举例的那些还有一个叫徐斌
徐斌他创作一个叫天书
什么叫天书呢
英文不是拼音字母吗
他把英文的每个字母变成书法体
原像篆隶楷行草
它赋予这个徐冰体
他用木科版的天书再转印出来
像这个就徐冰的天书
这个他转印过来你才看得懂了
但是就是转印过来你也看不懂
因为他是把每个英文字
变成我们中国的一个书法字
可能这个是一个一个一个英文单字的意思
这个就是艺术好玩的地方啊
他做大了你难以想象的地方
他的角度切入点是尼哦
原来可以这样子理解艺术哦
原来可以这样子做事情的
那再举个例子好了
像朱敏
朱敏不是太极系列吗
木雕的当初他刚磕完的时候
台湾的某一些木雕师傅就说这是粗胚诶
粗胚也可以嘛
因为他们理解是说木雕刻完之后要修
要喷砂要抹
可是他不要啊
他觉得磕完的这个形的这个线条
这个粗犷就是有味道的
他不愿意再加工了
那眼睛看不到他那么远的木雕师傅就嘲讽他
阿朱这个是粗胚啊
他是不是技术条件达不到
居然没有把作品再加工再细化再打磨
不是的
他这个做法等同于书法领域的魏碑
很粗犷
直接刻在岩石上呈现字体
所以呢很多事物的角度
你只要站的地方不一样
你看到的结果跟别人不一样
歌词创作也是当初我去创作歌词的时候
我就觉得说嗯你去写中国风的歌词的时候
变成一个个人的标签
变成一个个人的品牌
然后人家因为这样而认识你
然后再支持你去做别的创作
这个就是我的思维
我不怕别人贴标签说啊
那个就是写中国风的谁谁谁
那是又怎么样
因为很多艺术创作的领域
这个社会讯息太多了
草间弥生做了多少事
你就记得那个南瓜而已
朱明发表了多少东西
你就记得太极系列而已
重点是这就够了
这就够了
好的各位同学
这堂课是不是很有趣
这堂课叫什么叫歌词创作班
居然有出现当代艺术的绘画
这个就是说多方面的去开拓你的视野
让你的作品有景深重者它只是文字
让他有镜头感
这个很重要
像汝窑
我去研究汝窑
理解汝窑的时候
我发现说它基本上是宋代的极简主义
因为汝窑的样子款式很极简
它没有多余的线条
它不像清代的井太郎或唐代的唐三彩
它的颜色就一种很稳定
就是天青色
北宋时期以时间轴来看
你现在1000多年
但是汝窑的造型很当代艺术
因为它没有多余很繁琐
很几何的造型
人类的文明通常在进展中
一开始都是追求繁琐美
就像青铜器一样
那个年代觉得技术是艺术品的一个基本的条件
所以哇努力的做几何变化
做繁琐的雕花
云纹呐
他们没有想到说也可以抛弃这些
就是一个素胚
然后上玛瑙釉
玛瑙幼进窑烧的时候会呈现天青色
而且汝窑会开片
天哪开片多
特别你知道吗
开片是窑烧的温度造成釉料的表面裂开
叫冰裂纹
那古代人用开篇这个字去形容
就像花一样
开篇这个开片需要火候的协助
它往哪里开
你不晓得有这样子的东西
那那你不觉得说这世界很有趣吗
原来连瓷器都可以有这样子的极简主义
最后再举日本也是极简主义
日本的一个庭园里面有个枯山水的造景
我跟你讲
我很喜欢枯山水
为什么他是美学的信心
美学的话语权在他手上
怎么解释呢
以前一开始不管任何民族开始追求艺术的时候
一定会追求技术美
繁琐美
色彩美
尽量高难度
尽量制作上非常的困难
才能显现出这个工匠的价值
这个艺术品的地位
但是枯山水庭园造景
它不废话
他就是一片的白沙
象征流水
几颗岩石
象征山脉叫枯山水
他说这个就是美美
我说了算
极简主义到底了
美的话语权在他手上
所以呢我们去创作的时候
你也要有一个自己的风格在里面
最好让人家一觉得说哇
天哪可以这样子形容感情哇
天哪可以这样子用韵脚哇
原来文字可以排列的这么的特别
这个就是大家追求的目标
希望大家一堂一堂课继续的精进
而且要做笔记